on uh what is quickly becoming an
historic day or a historic day depending
on your grammatical preference uh it's
great to be joined by bill share who's a
contributor to the washington monthly
real clear politics politico
bill you know i i
let's
not immediately include the ukraine
russia situation in our conversation and
sort of start with like if this weren't
going on
what would your thoughts have been
on
where the 2022 midterms seem to be
looking in terms of
who's going to control the house and
senate um after november and and then
maybe we'll integrate
the question about russia ukraine um
well
you know in one respect you would say
things don't look good for democrats
uh obviously uh
anytime the president's party
is facing a midterm it tends to not go
great
um
we've had
36
midterms since the civil war and the
president's party loses house seats in
33 of those 36. uh now of course a lot
of those times they don't lose control
of congress because the margins are
bigger but now the margin is five so
even the slightest loss you are losing
control
and if biden's at the same job approval
in november as he is today which is
about 42 percent
that's not going to be
a good midterm
having said that there there are those
three exceptions
and there's also a fourth exception
where the democrat where democrats lost
less than five seats that was 1962. so
those four exceptions are 1934
1962 1998 2002. so what's what's the
thread in those exceptions
uh 34 is fdr's first term he's tackling
the great depression 62 cuban missile
crisis is solved 10 days before the
midterm 1998 republicans are
moving towards impeaching bill clinton
and there's a lot of talk in the air of
constitutional crisis
and 2002 we're still in the shadow of of
9 11.
crisis is the is the threat of those
four exceptions if you're
in the president's party and there's a
crisis and you're seen as handling that
crisis well right you can beat those
odds right now as it stands today we
have
again not counting ukraine um two big
crises that are intertwined the pandemic
in inflation
today
biden is not seen as handling those well
so that's not becoming a plus
it is certainly possible that by
november the pandemic's going to look a
lot better and inflation's going to look
a lot better
we can't say for certain today i mean
omicron's definitely already winding
down and we just don't know if another
new variant's gonna kick up between now
and then it's gonna throw us for another
loop um
but and ukraine is a third crisis and
again i'm not it's hardly
uh one cannot glibly say obayan's going
to take care of this fantastically it's
a very very complicated problem and even
the most fantastic president might have
handled it in the most perfect of ways
um but to add to that bill i mean no
matter what biden does republicans will
blame him i mean they're already doing
it last night trump with laura ingram
saying the problem here is biden and the
rigged election and people coming over
the u.s mexico border that he said
that's the cause of what's happening in
russia ukraine
uh you have a bunch of people already
saying he it's his fault and to some
degree that may stick at least in some
voters minds
well
let's not completely assume
that it's going to be
the unanimous republican message that
biden is
a weak leader and this is all this fault
so that's just out there pushed by trump
uh
uh
i'm not even going to argue that there's
a better than even odds the republicans
won't do that they very well could
but there is division
in the republican party on a number of
fronts and certainly ukraine is one of
those those issues and and policy versus
russia is one of those issues um
one thing i think
could help biden and democrats you know
both with ukraine and beyond
is to play up
bipartisanship
the reason why
the president's party usually does
poorly in midterms is you get a pendulum
swing
because
the governing party has to govern
governing is difficult
you have to make compromises you have to
you can't deliver on everything that
your base wants to see in the platform
unexpected crises occur
all these things put stress
on a diverse governing coalition and the
opposition can put aside their
differences and just focus on how much
they hate you that's the normal order of
midterm business
but we already have
um
secured some bipartisan victories the
biggest one being the infrastructure
bill
there are some smaller ones along with
that
and this is done with the help of mitch
mcconnell which has made donald trump
very mad donald trump actively attacks
mitch mcconnell for helping biden yeah
uh and
we've seen biden give conflicting
messages on the score sometimes he wants
to say oh we would do a lot better these
republicans weren't obstructing us and
sometimes he says we're making
washington work and getting things done
uh and i would lean more towards that
latter message than the former
because one it shows you are getting
things done electing us has been good
for you we've done some good things if
things aren't perfect in the universe um
and it drives wedges through the
opposition
so you want you want to be unified
yourself and divide the other guys right
and if binding can do things with
ukraine
that pull in
the more hawkish anti-putin types in the
republican party the lindsey grahams the
marco rubios the mitch mcconnells
uh
if it can make it uncomfortable for them
to side with trump that's going to
further help reverse the normal
trajectory of a midterm
i i can't help but think that if the
last four days
were not what they have been with
ukraine russia
there would be many discussions like the
ones my audience was having prior to
that point like for example
if biden can only forgive some student
loans between now and november if biden
can decriminalize cannabis federally
between now and over these types of
things which it quite frankly doesn't
seem biden has any interest at all in
doing many in my audience feel very
strongly that that would have a
significant impact on the outcome of the
midterms
what do you think about that well i mean
you gotta do two things i mean unifying
the party and splitting the opposition
requires two things you gotta do
something to energize your own base yes
and you gotta
don't take your eye off the swing the
swing still exists
um doing both those things is
complicated uh and there's an air
intentions there
i don't know if do what things you
suggest which are executive order things
which may go beyond what bayern thinks
is actually constitutional or illegal
and would be admitting price subject to
litigation
uh
that might not be in biden's comfort
zone i do think it would be greatly
helpful to get some significant piece of
what was called buildback better passed
um to
let that progressive base know hey this
was this wasn't a waste of your time
getting us elected we've done some
things that are significant significance
here right now the progressive base is
feeling that they've gotten the short
end of the stick and i understand that
and i do think you got to give them
something and so i see folks more
inclined to think about what can buy do
what can biden do by himself because i
don't trust joe manchin or chris cinema
to do anything helpful um
but
whatever it is
i think it needs to be something that
can get done and will stick yes um so
that progressive base feels like they
got something out of this part of why as
you laid out
uh it's not looking great for democrats
in november are these historical
realities that you laid out very clearly
regarding the 36 midterms since the
civil war the other part of it that i am
very strongly paying attention to
is that
it doesn't really seem democrats are
doing anything particularly helpful to
themselves in many ways and so i'm sort
of looking for help from republicans in
hurting themselves and one of the things
i'm looking at that i think is probably
okay for democrats is this sort of civil
war aspect of what's going on in the
republican party you've got it used to
be just pro and anti-trump but now
you've got the never trump the pro-trump
and the formerly pro-trump which are
increasingly sort of making some noise
it seems to me absent any great strategy
from democrats i welcome that sort of
infighting and it sounds like you're
saying in general division on the
opposite side is a good thing oh
absolutely and there's certainly things
that could happen
with trump's very aggressive involvement
in republican primaries right that's
going to be hurtful to republicans and
we can't know you know it's possible
trump backs a lunatic and that lunatic
wins the primary and wins general
election which is of course not good i
mean but we have examples in very recent
past where republicans have nominated
people
that threw away winnable seats you know
christine o'donnell in delaware um
todd aiken in missouri richard murdoch
in indiana
you know this is all pre-trump
and trump's not getting very involved in
all sorts of races senate and house and
governor uh you know one of the big you
know difficult races for democrats is
going to be georgia where rafael warnock
is uh holding on to
a seat very tenuously
uh and you got trump
pushing herschel walker who's got a
whole litany of scandals in his past yep
uh and
encouraging a bloodiest political civil
war between brian kemp and david perdue
uh so and if there's a there's a book
coming out called flip by greg bluestein
it's not quite out yet i just i just it
hasn't been published yet but i just
wrote a book review of it so i'm it's on
my mind i mean the things that
republicans did in georgia in the run-up
to 2020 are just comically ridiculous
and self-defeating um uh and you know
democrats did a lot of things right
republicans did a lot of things wrong
and democrats just barely won those
races so it's very possible that trump's
going to lead republicans at a very bad
path
uh and throw away
opportunities for them
at this point the specifically the
discussions of the election was stolen
who does that help and hurt in your
calculation
i mean look at the look at georgia it
that hurt republicans in georgia in 2020
for the runoffs yeah we know that
turnout went down in very red
conservative rural areas particularly in
the place where trump held rallies
between the november election the
january runoff uh so i i don't know that
will replicate
uh in 2022 but that is a risk for
republicans that if if
trump poisons the well
and tells folks that things are still
rigged that can hurt them now another
issue with 2022 is who's going to win
these secretary of state primaries
how many secretary of state races are
these issues going to be front and
center and how does that impact uh
turnout are they going to get pushed
above the fold that be more prominent
do they unify
the trumpian right and energize their
base or do they alienate those i mean
like like in georgia there was white
college educated romney-type voters that
were appalled right what trump was doing
and they moved to the democrats yeah so
there is that risk for republicans there
as well
in terms of some of the factions on the
left you know for a while there's been
pejoratively they're called tankies i
think a less pejorative term is the
revolutionary left
and you know they're kind of like
nicholas maduro's good and cool and
castro cuba it's cool and they were sort
of like pro putin but there's now this
other faction that i called the alt left
like for example glenn greenwald
and tulsi gabbard they're not
revolutionary left but they certainly
seem to be this alt-left thing they were
saying putin's not gonna invade all this
stuff
are these factions how sizeable do you
think these factions are in terms of the
people that actually vote beca and the
reason i ask it that way is in the 2020
democratic primary
if you looked on reddit and twitter you
would have dramatically overestimated
the level of support for someone like
bernie but when it came to voting in the
primary that was not where the
democratic party was at the time so like
how big do you think these factions are
well i mean i think the bernie faction
is a whole lot bigger than the tulsi
factory oh absolutely without a doubt
i mean i think greenwald has really
discredited himself amongst much of the
left like he's really what he's held on
to is you know tulsi left which is which
is a splinter yeah you know he's mostly
celebrated on the right these days
uh than the left so i mean there is this
sort of horseshoe you know dynamic where
people have this kind of mix of mixed
positions and uh they're generally
you know anti-deep state anti-american
establishment anti-industrial complex
establishment they lump a lot of things
into that that rubric um
to the point where they go as far as say
as greenwald apparently is arguing that
this isn't really an invasion um that
america brought this on because i mean
there's a there's a jackman article
saying well uh that's a little
not as
commentary to putin as some others but
saying well it's not it's not all
putin's fault because we wouldn't do the
compromise where you we say ukraine
can't be a nato uh and
i understand there's there's certainly
times in life where you do some
strategic ambiguity to avoid to avoid
conflict but it's pretty clear that
ukraine has a good reason to want to be
in nato because bruin is hell-bent on on
occupying them they want that protection
so they don't get obliterated uh and so
it's hard for me to
take that off the equate out of the
equation when looking at the situation
uh so i mean that those voices are out
there they're certainly
easy to hear in social media because
they're loud right but as far as their
impact electorally i think it's very
small yeah and it seems the effect is
more getting those people to stay home
because they it's sort of like in the
2016 the alt left in 2016 often seem to
argue it's kind of irrelevant whether
it's trump or hillary and to me it
seemed less about it turned votes from
hillary to trump than it just made some
people stay home who probably would have
voted for hillary
yeah and and we didn't have that in
2020. i mean
people were angered for trump without
whatever
their idiosyncratic foreign policy views
were
or whatever their concerns about how
moderate biden would be
that became secondary to stopping trump
i mean right the classic example you you
put aside your differences you unify
around the common enemy uh and
uh look
dealing with ukraine
it's not going to be
necessarily easy to unite a broad swath
of america around whatever policy we
adopt because it's particularly if we're
doing something that is um
somewhat aggressive and we know no one's
talking about you know troops on the
ground of course but even even economic
sanctions could
get blow back where russia does economic
things to us or cyber attacks on us and
creates disruption and discomfort within
america
it's not a given that the average
american is going to appreciate that and
and and
believe that this is worth the sacrifice
that we're doing it's going to take
rhetorical effort on the part of this is
where
bipartisanship would help
you know as much as you and i might
really think marco rubio is appalling or
lindsey graham was appalling
just as a matter of politics yeah if
buying into saying
we gotta take these these actions to
check putin and it's gonna mean some
hurt at the pump it's gonna mean some
uh complications with our cyber
infrastructure we're gonna do our best
to counter it uh but you gotta expect
it's gonna be hard sometimes
if a rubio and a gram and a macau giving
biting cover and saying he's doing the
right thing
that's going to mitigate the ability for
those
on like you know alt-left types
uh who are going to or carlson types are
going to push into the media bloodstream
why are we doing this
biden is making you pay five dollars the
pump for what ukraine why should you
care about that um people on on the
fringes are going to push that argument
and it's an argument that can have some
traction yeah um so so in that respect
they're relevant players
uh you know if they're not necessarily
electorally large uh and the more
diverse cover biden has for whatever
actions he takes the better he's gonna
be able to withstand that and try to get
the american people on his side well the
next five days both in terms of what
happens in ukraine russia and then up to
and including what biden chooses to say
at a state of the union address are
definitely going to be uh
worth worth following we've been
speaking with bill share contributor to
the washington monthly real clear
politics politico bill always great
having you on
great to talk to you take care